well as you've been saying this is the
beginning of a reset
uh the the diplomats on both sides are
not even using the word reset because
they say that they are not there yet
there is some way to go it's about
rewriting
uh the the the rule book um creating an
understanding
between the two leaders you can see them
behind me there
um about 50 meters or so away from us
they arrived
one after the other mr putin or the
swiss president first and then president
putin
and then about 50 10 minutes or so later
president
biden they all went in and have just
emerged again
for this photo called the swiss
president you can see there moving to
one side
and there we are the two men shaking
hands that first handshake that we have
seen between the two of them
as they will now head in separately for
those talks talks that will take place
first of all
in a one plus one scenario
so we will see uh in a one plus one
scenario um
the two presidents with their respective
foreign ministers and then later on more
diplomats
will join those meetings which are
expected to last through the course of
the afternoon and then later on
there will be news conferences separate
news conferences um
between the two leaders there was a
suggestion at one stage perhaps they'd
do one together in the way that
presidents trump and putin did three
years ago but no
they will be separate i think to avoid
any potential diplomatic
fallout